[موسيقى]
لقب بابي الكوميديا ورسخ مفاهيم الفن
الساخري في العالم اجمع
اريستوفان رائد المسرح الكوميدي في
اليونان ومؤلف ذاع صيته في الفن الساخر
ولد في العام 1446 قبل الميلاد وانحدر من
اسره مثقفه غنيه من طبقه ملاك الاراضي في
اثينا
عصر الحرب بين اثينا واسبرتا لتشكل بعد
ذلك مصدر الهام له في مسرحياته واخذ يمدد
بهذا التطاحن الذي يقتل فيه اليوناني اخاه
ويدعو في كل مسرحيه يكتبها الى السلم
كانت مسرحيته تغص بالنكات والمبالغات
والنقد السياسي اللاذع على الرغم من
الباسها بمهاره فائقه ثوب العبارات
الهزليه
سخريته قادته الى المحاكمه عندما سخر من
كليون الذي قبض على الحكم في اثنا في
مسرحيه مفقوده تدعى البابليون وحكم عليه
بالخيانه ودفع غرامه ماليه
سار اريستوفان لنفسه بعد عامين من هذا
الحكم باخراج مسرحيته الفرسان وفيها سخر
من كليون مره اخرى
لم يكتفي بانتقاد الشخصيات العامه بل هجمه
ايضا اصحاب الفكر الجديد من السفصائيين
ولم يترك اي فرصه تمر في مسرحياته دون ان
يستثمرها لتسفيه الفلاسفه بوجه عام وفي
مقدمتهم سقراط مثلما فعل في مسرحيه السحب
يعتقد انه الف نحو 50 مسرحيه تغطي جوانب
الحياه الاثينيه في زمنه ولم يتبقى منها
الا 11 مسرحيه ابرزها السلام الطيور ملهاه
الضفادع الاستراتي برلمان النساء
توفي في العام
386 قبل الميلاد عن عمر ناهز 60 عاما
من اقواله الوطن هو حيث يكون المرء في خير
[موسيقى]